foreign  [Music]  a world of wonder  and mystery  from the Hallelujah mountains to the  endless rainforest  but there is so much more to the  spectacular and Mysterious World  The Cliffs of Pandora give way to a  mighty ocean  and a Tropical Haven teeming with life  over 50 Navi Clans live in the reefs the  largest is the Met kaina  they live in harmony with the Majestic  tolkun the fierce skim wing and the  playful elude  beyond the great sea wall the akula lay  and wait  much like the rainforest every living  organism in this coastal biome has  bioluminescent qualities that set the  night a glow emitting light in  breathtaking patterns  all things are interconnected on Pandora  from the tiniest organisms to the  Towering tofun  amidst the beauty of the ocean and the  fierce terrain the Magnificent creatures  of the skies  and the sea  wherever we turn  a thrilling World awaits